this is my grandfather
this is my son
my grandfather taught me to work with
wood when i was a little boy
and he also taught me the idea that if
you cut down a tree to turn it into
something
honor that tree's life and make it as
beautiful as you possibly can
my little boy
reminded me
that for all the technology and all the
toys in the world sometimes just a small
block of wood if you stack it up tall
actually is an incredibly inspiring
thing
these are my buildings
i build all around the world out of our
office in vancouver and new york
and we build buildings of different
sizes and styles and different materials
depending on where we are but what is
the material that i love the most and
i'm going to tell you the story about
wood and part of the reason i love it is
that every time people go into my
buildings that are wood i notice they
react completely differently i've never
seen anybody walk into one of my
buildings and hug a steel or a concrete
column but i've actually seen that
happen in a wood building i've actually
seen how people touch the wood and i
think there's a reason for it
just like snowflakes no two pieces of
wood can ever be the same anywhere on
earth
that's a wonderful thing
i like to think that wood
gives mother nature fingerprints in our
buildings
it's mother nature's fingerprints that
make our buildings connect us to nature
in the built environment
now i live in vancouver near a forest
that grows to 33 stories tall
down the coast here in california the
redwood forest grows to 40 stories tall
but the buildings that we think about in
wood are only four stories tall in most
places on earth
even building codes actually limit the
ability for us to build
much taller than four stories in many
places and that's true here in the
united states now there are exceptions
but there needs to be some exceptions
and things are going to change i'm
hoping and the reason i think that way
is that today half of us live in cities
and that number is going to grow to 75
percent
cities and density mean that our
buildings are going to continue to be
big
and i think there's a role for wood to
play in cities
and i feel that way because
3 billion people in the world today over
the next 20 years will need a new home
that's 40 percent of the world are going
to need a new building built for them in
the next
20 years
now one in three people living in cities
today actually live in a slum
it's one billion people in the world
live in slums
hundred million people in the world
are homeless
the scale of the challenge for
architects and for society to deal with
in building is to find a solution
to house these people
but the challenge is as we move to
cities
cities are built in these two materials
steel and concrete and they're great
materials
they're the materials of the last
century but they're also materials with
very high energy and very high
greenhouse gas
emissions in their process
steel represents about three percent of
man's greenhouse gas emissions and
concrete is over five percent
so if you think about that eight percent
of our contribution to to greenhouse
gases today
comes from those two materials alone
we don't think about it a lot and then
unfortunately we actually don't even
think about buildings i think as much as
we should this is a u.s statistic about
the impact of greenhouse gases
almost half of our greenhouse gases are
related to the building industry and if
we look at energy it's the same story
you'll notice that transportation sort
of second down that list but that's the
conversation we mostly hear about
and although a lot of that is about
energy
it's also so much about carbon
the problem i see is that ultimately the
clash of how we solve that problem of
serving those three billion people that
need a home and climate change are
head-on collision about to happen or
already happening
that challenge means that we have to
start thinking in new ways and i think
wood is going to be part of that
solution i'm going to tell you the story
of why as an architect wood is the only
material big material that i can build
with that's already grown by the power
of the sun
when a tree grows in the forest and
gives off oxygen and soaks up carbon
dioxide
and it dies and it falls to the forest
floor
it gives that carbon dioxide back to the
atmosphere into the ground if it burns
in a forest fire it's going to give that
carbon back to the atmosphere as well
but if you take that wood and you put it
into a building or into a piece of
furniture or into that wooden toy it
actually has amazing capacity to store
the carbon and provide us with a
sequestration
one cubic meter of wood
will store one ton of carbon dioxide
now our two solutions to climate are
obviously to reduce our emissions and
find storage
what is the only major building material
i can build with that actually does both
those two things
so i believe that we have
an ethic that the earth grows our our
food and we need to move to an ethic in
this century that the earth should grow
our homes
now how are we going to do that when
we're urbanizing at this rate and we
think about wood buildings only at four
stories we need to reduce the concrete
and steel we need to grow bigger and
what we've been working on is 30 story
tall
buildings made of wood
we've been engineering them with
an engineer america named eric karch who
works with me on it
and we've been doing this new work
because there are new wood products out
there for us to use and we call them
mass timber panels these are panels made
with young trees
small growth trees small pieces of wood
glued together to make panels that are
enormous eight feet wide 64 feet long
and of various thicknesses
the way i describe this best i i've
found is to say that we're all used to
two by four construction when we think
about wood that's what people jump to as
a conclusion
two by four construction sort of like
the little eight dog bricks of lego that
we all played with as kids and you can
make all kinds of cool things out of
lego at that size and out of two by
fours
but you remember when you're a kid and
you kind of sifted through the pile in
your basement and you found that big 24
dot brick of lego and you were kind of
like cool this is awesome i can build
something really big and this is going
to be great
that's the change mass timber panels are
those 24 dot bricks they're changing the
scale of what we can do and what we've
developed is something we call fftt
which is a creative commons solution
to building
a very
flexible system
of building with these large panels
where we tilt up six stories at a time
if we want to
this animation shows you how the
building goes together in a very simple
way but these buildings are available
for architects and engineers now to
build on for different cultures in the
world different architectural styles and
characters in order for us
to build safely and we've engineered
these buildings actually to work in a
vancouver context where we're a high
seismic zone even at 30 stories tall
now obviously every time i bring this up
people even you know here at the
conference say are you serious 30
stories how's that going to happen and
there's a lot of really
good questions that are asked and
important questions that we spent quite
a long time working on the answers to as
we put together our our report and the
peer-reviewed report i'm just going to
focus on a few of them let's start with
fire because i think fire is probably
the first one that you're all thinking
about right now yeah fair enough and the
way i describe it is this
if i asked you to take a match and light
it and hold up a log and try to get that
log to go on fire it doesn't happen
right we all know that but to build a
fire you kind of start with small pieces
of wood and you work your way up and
eventually you can add the log to the
fire
and when you do add the log to the fire
of course it burns but it burns slowly
well mass timber panels these new
products that we're using are much like
the log it's hard to start them on fire
and when they do they actually burn
extraordinarily predictably and we can
use fire science in order to predict and
make these buildings as safe as concrete
and the safest steel
the next big issue deforestation
18 of our contribution to greenhouse gas
emissions worldwide as the result of
deforestation the last thing we want to
do is cut down trees
or the last thing we want to do is cut
down the wrong trees
there are models for sustainable
forestry that allow us to cut trees
properly and those are the only trees
appropriate to use for these kinds of
systems now i actually think that these
ideas will change the economics of
deforestation
in countries with deforestation issue we
need to find a way to provide
better value for the forest
and actually encourage people to make
money through very fast growth cycles 10
12 15 year old trees that make these
products and allow us to build at this
scale
we've calculated a 20-story building
will grow enough wood in north america
every 13 minutes that's how much
it takes
the carbon story here is a really good
one
if we built a 20-story building out of
cement and concrete the process would
result in the manufacturing of that
cement and 1200 tons of carbon dioxide
if we did it in wood
in this solution we'd sequester about 3
100 tons for a net difference of 43 100
tons that's the equivalent of about 900
cars removed from the road in one year
think back to that three billion people
that need a new home and maybe this is a
contributor to reducing
we're at the beginning of a revolution i
hope in the way we build because this is
the first new way to build a skyscraper
in probably 100 years or more
but the challenge is changing society's
perception of possibility and it's a
huge challenge the engineering is
truthfully the easy part of this and the
way i describe it is this the first
skyscraper technically in the definition
of a skyscraper is 10 stories tall
believe it or not but the first
skyscraper was this one in chicago and
people were terrified to walk underneath
this building but only four years after
it was built gustavel was building an
eiffel tower
and as he built the eiffel tower he
changed the skylines
of the cities of the world
um changed
and created a competition between places
like new york city and chicago where
developers started building bigger and
bigger buildings and pushing the the
envelope up higher and higher with
better and better engineering
we built this model in new york actually
on the as a theoretical model in the
campus of a technical university soon to
come and the reason we picked this site
to just show you what these buildings
may look like because they can the
exterior can change it's really just the
structure that we're talking about
the reason we picked it is because this
is a technical university and i believe
that wood is the most technologically
advanced material i can build with it
just happens to be the mother nature
holds the patent and we don't really
feel comfortable with it
but that's the way it should be
nature's fingerprints in the built
environment
i'm looking for this opportunity to
create an eiffel tower moment we call it
buildings are starting to go up around
the world there's a building in london
that's nine stories a new building that
just finished in australia that i
believe is 10 or 11. we're starting to
push the height up of of these wood
buildings and we're hoping and i'm
hoping that my hometown of vancouver
actually potentially announces the
world's tallest at around 20 stories
in the not so distant future
that eiffel tower moment will break the
ceiling these arbitrary ceilings of
height and allow wood buildings to join
the competition and i believe the race
is ultimately on thank you
[Music]
you